SAME THING IN THE TEXTS, OTHER
THAN I TOLD HIM THAT.
TO MY RECOLLECTION, HE
IMMEDIATELY GOT UP AND LEFT HIS
OFFICE.
>> OUR INVESTIGATION FOUND
IMMEDIATELY AFTER THE
PRESIDENT'S 2:24 P.M. TWEET, THE
CROWDS BOTH OUTSIDE THE CAPITOL
AND INSIDE THE CAPITOL SURGED.
THE CROWDS INSIDE THE CAPITOL
WERE ABLE TO OVERWHELM THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT PRESENCE AND THE
VICE PRESIDENT WAS QUICKLY
EVACUATED FROM HIS CEREMONIAL
OFFICE TO A SECURE LOCATION
WITHIN THE CAPITOL COMPLEX BY
2:24 P.M., THE SECRET SERVICE
MOVED VICE PRESIDENT MIKE PENCE
FROM THE SENATE CHAMBER TO HIS
OFFICE ACROSS THE HALL.
>> THE NOISE BECAME AUDIBLE TO
WHICH POINT WE RECOGNIZED MAYBE
THEY HAD GOTTEN INTO THE
BUILDING.
>> THEN PRESIDENT TRUMP TWEETED
MIKE PENCE DIDN'T HAVE THE
COURAGE TO DO WHAT SHOULD HAVE
BEEN DONE TO PROTECT OUR COUNTRY
AND OUR CONSTITUTION, GIVING
STATES A CHANCE TO CERTIFY A
CORRECTED SET OF FACT, NOT THE
FRAUDULENT OR ENACT RAT ONES
WHICH THEY WERE ASKED TO
PREVIOUSLY CERTIFY.
USA DEMANDS THE TRUTH!
>> IT WAS CLEAR IT WAS
ESCALATING AND ESCALATING
QUICKLY.
>> SO THEN WHEN THAT TWEET, MIKE
PENCE TWEET WAS SENT OUT, I
REMEMBER US SAYING THAT THAT WAS
THE THING THAT NEEDED TO BE
TWEETED AT THAT MOMENT.
THE SITUATION WAS ALREADY BAD.
IT FELT LIKE HE WAS POURING
GASOLINE ON THE FIRE WHEN HE
TWEETED THAT.
>> 30 SECOND LATER RIOTERS
OPENED THE EAST ROTUNDA HALL
DOWN THE HALL.
JUST 30 SECOND AFTER THEYIOTERS
BREACHED THE CRYPT, BELOW THE
VICE PRESIDENT.
>> THE SECRET SERVICE COULDN'T
CONTROL THE SITUATION OF DOING
THEIR JOB OF KEEPING HIM SENSE.
>> THEY RUSHED VICE PRESIDENT
PENCE DOWN THE STAIRS.
>> I THINK THEY WERE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT WHETHER THEY HAD A
CLEAR ROUTE TO GET US TO WHERE
IT WAS THEY WANTED TO MOVE US
TO.
>> WE MOVED QUICKLY DOWN THE
STAIRS THROUGH VARIOUS HALLWAYS
AND TUNNELS TO A SECURE
LOCATION.
UPON ARRIVING THERE, THERE WAS
FURTHER DISCUSSION WHETHER WE
WERE GOING TO LEAVE THE CAPITOL
COMPLEX OR STAY WHERE WE WERE.
>> VICE PRESIDENT PENCE AND HIS
TIME ULTIMATELY WERE LED TO A
SECURE LOCATION, WHERE THEY
STAYED FOR THE NEXT
FOUR-AND-A-HALF HOURS.
BARELY MISSING RIOTERS, A FEW
FEET AWAY.
>> APPROXIMATELY 40 FEET.
THAT'S ALL THERE WAS.
40 FEET BETWEEN THE VICE
PRESIDENT AND THE MOB.
MR. JACOB, YOU WERE THERE,
SEEING THAT FOR THE FIRST TIME,
DOES IT SURPRISE YOU TO SEE HOW
CLOSE THE MOB WAS TO THE
EVACUATION ROUTE YOU TOOK?
40 FEET IS THE DISTANCE FROM ME
TO YOU, ROUGHLY?
>> I COULD H